today I'll stick to football it is mock
draft Monday time we're gonna take you 1
332 and look back at the weekend the
Heisman Trophy was handed out and also
answer your draft on draft questions
Conor it is good to see you buddy I
missed you last week yeah good to see
you welcome back nice to see that you're
healthy we were getting worried there
for a while it got to the point where we
had to call in a full show replacement
for one time in Luke Voight that's how
worried we were about you Matt so we had
a little tryout but we decided to keep
you buddy yeah you know Luke did a good
job
fellow Missouri boy holding it down but
I think when it comes to the draft I
might have him he sounded like a riot I
was really sad I missed that show mellow
text me right after and he's like that
was the best interview we've ever had so
there's a lot of fun maybe I just need
to get out of the way more often I'll
tell you what I saw the best YouTube
comment we've ever gotten it was at the
top because it got so many thumbs up the
top comment for the show was Luke looks
like the two hosts meshed together me
and Melo put into one yellow we're
combined into a human being so great I
could see it yeah I could see it no
thanks to Luke for stopping by and
hanging out with you guys but we do have
a lot to get into today in terms of new
mock draft the draft order is shaking up
as we get down to the wire here with the
playoff race and especially with like
teams don't want to lose the Giants win
that's gonna affect things as we head
into week 16 but first and foremost
congrats to Joe burrow from LSU winning
the Heisman Trophy the largest whenever
largest in terms of the percent of
ballots he was on the points that he won
by in the Heisman it's like the
Electoral College no one completely
understands it but you basically give
people points and that's how they win
this thing but congrats to Joe burrow
who was very deserving I think we had
all said that you know Melo and I talked
about it quite a bit in the week prior
of you know we felt like this guy was
hands-down gonna win it even though
chase young deserved a lot a lot of
mention I thought that the two
quarterbacks Justin Fields had a great
year statistically Jalen hurts what he
did just you know keeping that oklahoma
train rolling but joe burrow connor
to me i don't remember a lot of Heisman
Trophy speeches and I mean I watch it
every year it's our job I thought Joe
Borowski CH was a
amazing and not it wasn't like this
well-written you know we're gonna look
back on and it's gonna be like a JFK
speech but the rawness and the emotion
it was it was a really hard to watch and
not get emotional as well to see just
the relief that he felt and the pride
that he felt and then you know to shout
out his hometown Athens Ohio and the
struggles there I thought he did an
amazing job I thought so too and I
thought if you needed to know why people
for a long time before this magical year
LS you have said nothing but great
things about Joe borough the person
whether it's the camps he was at or why
he was so loved when he got to ohio say
and why a lot of people were rooting for
him at ohio state and why a lot of
people that are Buckeye fans and college
football fans rooted for him even after
he left and when he went to LSU that's
what makes Joe burrow so special I think
obviously teams are gonna fall in love
with him it doesn't matter that they
will because he's going number one to
the Cincinnati Bengals so they're the
only team that matters in all of this
but for Joe borough and I believe he you
know somebody said that he didn't write
a speech he just went up there and spoke
it goes to show you how genuine and
natural he is and that stuff really does
matter for a quarterback at the next
level at the highest level of football
and I think it was awesome to watch and
I think it was great he started with
thanking his offensive line you could
see how the relationship he has with
Coach oh and we've always said this
about coach oh he might not be the best
in-game coach in college football and
that's not an insult to him it's just
that he's not the best at it but the
other things he does so well
relationships with players recruiting
developing players it is another thing
that's made him you know so great for
that LSU program that top ranked LSU
program and for borough it was an
awesome way to cap off what's just been
such a great regular season run yeah it
has been
and so well-deserved I do want to talk
about chase Young who finished fourth
that sub attacked me I really thought he
would finish second and that's I said
that's how my ballot would go which we
don't have a vote here stick to football
not collectively and not individually I
would have voted a borough chase Young
justa field's Jalen Hurd
and I feel like that was pretty logical
I understand some people may be one that
penalize chase young because the
two-game suspension but I don't know how
you can idea I guess I don't know if
you're gonna put him on the ballot how
is he not first or second if you're
gonna vote for the guy what makes you
put him fourth instead of second or
first and I haven't seen any voters come
out and explain why they had him where
they did I saw Bruce Feldman put Sewell
the Oregon left tackle in second place
like I and he explained his vote I
thought okay like that was a dominant
left tackle didn't give up a sack all
year he's been an amazing player I get
it
but I don't quite understand why people
are overlooking chase young still 16 and
a half sacks 20 tackles for a loss if
you watched college football on
Saturdays you know he was the most
dominant player in the sport I'm with
you all the way Matt and I'm a little
confused by what this award really
represents anymore is it its definition
which is the most outstanding player in
college football
because if that's the case how chase
young is not at least second doesn't add
up to me and a lot of people pointed
this out on Twitter when I tweeted about
it they were saying that he had the
second-most first-place votes so for him
to finish fourth means that a lot of
people there's a big chunk of voters
that didn't think really include him
didn't take him seriously and I think
this is my problem with the Heisman
Trophy is that there is a large section
of voters that and I understand a vote
is an opinion and you have the right to
that but if you're not even getting him
in the conversation you should not have
a vote
you obviously are not evil not watching
the games or you treat it as the best
quarterback in the country because I
always go back to you and mean you both
said this a lot and mellow on the third
on our Friday show the trophy has really
become the best player on the best team
yeah you might not be the best player in
the country I mean Shuba hubbard
finished in 7th or 8th and do you think
Chuba hubbard was the 7th or 8th best
player in the country this year no he
was way better than that
but the problem is chase Young was the
best player for an undefeated team and
he finished fourth yeah he's truly one
the best team
it is and I know chase young won't care
if they win a national championship and
he this segues perfectly it came out
over the weekend from TMZ of all places
that chase Young says he's not worried
about the NFL and his plans to come back
now he walked that back a little bit
Saturday night can we just say that this
is the perfect right now comment ever
like right now he's probably not worried
about the NFL Draft he's worried about
Ohio State and the cost well playoff he
also doesn't have to worry because he
knows he's gonna be the first or second
pick overall
if a team knee if the Bengals have the
pick it's gonna be Joe burrow does
anyone else is gonna be chase young
there we go put a period on it it's done
so he doesn't have to worry if chase
young were to go back to Ohio State for
a senior it would be the biggest
surprise ever they in terms of the NFL
Draft it would be the biggest surprise
ever
yeah it would I mean when you look at
what Andrew Luck did I think everybody
had already known how obsessed with
being at Stanford Andrew Luck was he was
just a different kind of guy and I'm not
saying chase isn't like that with Ohio
State but much like luck
chase doesn't have anything left to
prove here no I mean he really really
doesn't the Heisman committee just
showed him you can be the best defensive
player in the country and possibly the
best player in the country we're not
going to consider you we're not you
finished fourth the chances of him
replicating that season Matt
statistically are probably less than 10%
because teams are gonna triple team them
every game if you don't you're you're a
fool so I think I also think it's a
problem with and I've noticed it more so
this year a lot of people getting ahead
of themselves there's a huge problem
with the reporting of players deciding
to return back to school or go to the
draft oh yeah where they're almost not
allowed to make up their minds or given
the cushion of time things change we say
it all the time things change somebody
else gets hurt and someone changes their
mind cuz they can capitalize on the
stock they might have the game of their
life at the end of the year and they're
being told listen we saw everything we
needed to see in that game you got to
get out while it's hot Cardale Jones he
probably should have left that year and
he didn't but the
problem is I mean TMZ coming out and
chase young said the right thing he's
worried about winning a national title
right now he's not thinking about the
NFL Draft and he'll have the required
time to think about that when the
college football playoff is over yeah
absolutely let's find out how early he
goes and our mock draft Monday we'll be
back right after this the Cincinnati
Bengals still only first pick in the
draft Connor Rodgers you weren't on the
clock buddy who's gonna be I already set
it in around the league let's not let's
not beat around the bush here it's
jobber oh it's as simple as that now as
we get closer to the draft we'll talk
about Joe burrows impact for the Bengals
and all that good stuff but considering
we got 31 other picks here today Matt
let's move on to number two and that's
the New York Giants yeah and this is
also a no brainer whether it's Dave
gentlemen or me and you run in the draft
it's gonna be chase young is to pick
here it this is the easiest one to I can
remember since Jared Goff Carson Wentz
where wheeze knew who it was gonna be
and chase young to the Giants it's a
need it's a value it's a perfect fit for
them now I think it's interesting to
bring this up today's show we have 3 3
and 11 teams right now Matt yeah the
Giants dolphins Redskins the Lions only
have three wins but they have a tie so
strength of schedule is gonna be huge
here but as a lot of these teams in the
bottom four or top for the draft play
each other this week this is a huge
draft weekend we have coming up and if
you're the Giants I've said it over and
over again you want to keep losing for
chase young you really do and if that's
the case I'll go ahead and Matt you got
a elías win now stop like now stop stop
winning hit the brakes number three the
Miami Dolphins a team a lot of people
thought would be picking one or two they
could still jump up to number two when
all is said and done but three here I'm
going with to a tongue of I Aloha back
back to what we already thought for a
long time I think a lot of there's a lot
of medical questions about 2a but I
can't answer those right now and I can't
answer those until we get out to Indy
and I want to go with the glass half
full approach for tua I still think the
talent is top three pick kind of talent
for him I hope it all works out for him
and I think if he checks out medically
the Dolphins cannot pass up on him here
yeah I like that number for the
Washington Redskins hey it's working out
pretty well with some Ohio State guys -
Wayne Haskins scary Terry McLaren let's
get one more Jeff Okuda at corner not
only does the Buckeye pipeline work here
but he's also he's the best corner in
the draft he's the best corner I've
evaluated since Jalen Ramsey he fits
perfectly yeah Josh Norman is terrible
they need to get better at the corner
position yes they need a left tackle we
all know that I feel like it's still too
early for Jedrek wills or Andrew Thomas
or Tristan warps maybe they would trade
back but in in a mock draft Monday
without trades Jeff Okuda is the best
pick for them yeah I love that I think
accout is a top-five player in this
class at a premium position in today's
NFL and he would be perfect for
Washington at number four number five
the Detroit Lions they really really
should have taken probably a guy like
and Oliver or some kind of defensive
lineman last year they can solve that
this year at number five with Derrick
brown he is unblockable he is
unstoppable I love watching this guy
play I love watching him take over
against the run he has a really good
motor as a pass rusher I don't know if
Matt Patricia is gonna be there next
year but it doesn't matter Derrick Brown
should be the pick here at number five
it almost feels like Derrick Brown's
underrated which is crazy if you've like
watched him play he's um he's really
really good but he just he's almost been
lost in this class because the
quarterbacks and the receivers but III
do believe he's a top seven or eight guy
in this class and Detroit would be very
very smart to pick him number six the
Arizona Cardinals Larry Fitzgerald is
gonna be done in the desert they need a
number one receiver they need a lot of
things but I think they need a number
one receiver most importantly I'm gonna
go Jerry Judy here I think his agility
his the braking ability out of routes
how explosive he is that is perfect for
the Arizona offense now I I will say
Judy has dropped some passes the second
half of this season that have concerned
me because he's just letting the ball
get into his body I didn't see him do
that last year I don't know if it's just
I don't know what it is I don't know if
he's trying to protect himself I don't
know if he's overthinking it but there
is a little bit of concern there he's
still the top receiver for me but I
don't think it's this where it used to
be like Judy was up here by himself and
then there was everyone else
I think CD lamb I think Henry rugs T
Higgins is a really good
receiver class I still think Judy's the
best but he has not separated himself
from the pack like I thought he would
this year yeah there was a time where
Judy was consistently going number two
or number three in these mock drafts so
you know a couple of spots back for him
now but we still love his talent and
speaking of those wide receivers that
are creeping up on him number seven in
the New York Jets I don't think this
will be a Joe Douglas pick I think
they'll reach on an offensive lineman if
they can't get a corner like Jeff Okuda
but if I was making this pick I would go
with CD lamb I would be really
aggressive with the offensive line and
trades and free agency so I don't
pigeonhole myself into some kind of top
seven reache here the Jets listen you
could sit there and argue all day they
need offensive line I won't argue back
they also need a number one wide
receiver for Sam darn 'old yeah very
very badly and CD lamb is that guy man
Sam looks so good at times but he just
needs help I mean he's throwing the guys
who I've never even heard of and in
running first life exactly and yelling
and Adam GaSe poor David fails on the
sidelines that's my favorite video of
the weekend that shocks bass oh my god
it's like it's like the first time he
had ever heard mom and dad fight number
eight the Jacksonville Jaguars they have
two picks around one with this one I'm
going to give them their left tackle the
future Jedrek wills who I was going to
spend all last week finishing my
offensive line rankings and then I got
the flu so it hasn't happened what I've
seen from wills makes me think he might
be my top tackle in this class and I
want to watch a couple more games before
I it'll come to that full opinion but I
like wills his movement skills are
really good what he does in the run game
getting to the second level I think you
play left tackle in the NFL I really
don't have any questions about that
because he's just agile enough he asked
the body type he has two strengths the
Jags
I think they have something the Gardner
Minshew I really do let's protect him
give him the help they haven't given
some of these other quarterbacks
Jedrek wills gonna be the left tackle
the future.there yeah I'm with you that
offensive line needs help I think what a
better offensive line they can keep
developing Gardner like you said and
Matt how about a quiet over thousand
yards on the ground for Leonard
fournette this year I know the last
couple games he's kind of stumbled a
little bit I don't think the blocking
has been there but it's good to see from
net turn it on in year number three for
Jackson
vil hopefully him in gardener can kind
of be the guys next year when they get a
foundation in front of them number nine
the Los Angeles chargers we've said this
pick a lot this seems like the ideal
landing spot for Justin Herbert whether
that's sitting behind Phillip Rivers if
he comes back next year or Tyrod Taylor
I'm okay with that I just think this is
a quiet place for Herbert to go develop
where he doesn't have to be forced into
a starting job he stays on the west
coast and the Chargers Matt they need
their quarterback in the future I can
really see them swinging for the fences
at this spot of the draft yeah I can to
it and Phillip Rivers is gonna be a
hall-of-famer he has been a great
quarterback for last was 1516 years it's
it's done he he does not look good out
on the field so they got to get somebody
else in there number 10 the Denver
Broncos I think they might have their
quarterback of the future drew Locke
came back to earth a little bit in a
snowstorm in Kansas City but has still
shown flashes one thing that stands out
whether you've watched one game this
year or every Broncos game they have to
protect better Garrett Bowles just not
getting it done JaJuan Johnson has been
completely hurt on the right side I'm
gonna give them Andrew Thomas left
tackle from Georgia I don't know if he
stays at left tackle in the NFL I could
see him moving over to the right side
but for the Broncos they just have to
invest in that old line because if they
do have a guy in drew lock they can
build around and we'll see how he looks
the next two weeks but you have to
believe he goes into next year starting
quarterback for Denver and they have to
help him out I think so too I think to
see what you have in him and we knew he
was pretty raw coming in you want to add
as much pieces as you can around him
number 11 the Carolina Panthers this is
probably the highest we've had him I'm
going Christian Fulton here Matt I've
gotten to catch up on some of his
coaches film last week when it became
official he'll be at the Senior Bowl
when you watch him against Alabama they
ask him one on one to cover guys like
Henry rug's Jerry Judy Devante Smith
really a lot of rugs in that game and of
course there's gonna be a couple of
times where rugs is just simply faster
but fallen is scrappy he moves very very
well he sees the ball I'm blown away but
I mean we saw him in person against
Georgia last year during the 2018 season
I thought he really stood out in that
game but I think he's made the
legitimate
to being a top 15 pick in this class and
for the Panthers if you can keep
stacking up secondary pieces while you
have some pieces up front that defense
can be very very good yeah it really can
be and I think with Fulton another thing
remember he's played hurt a lot this
year so people are gonna say oh like I
saw him do this in this game or whatever
he's been playing on a hurt ankle and I
think did that speak see his toughness
his leadership is off the charts good I
have a higher grade on him than I had on
greedy and he was my top corner last
year so really really like Christian
pull number 12 the Atlanta Falcons I've
been playing they're just asses off
lately for tank Quinn how many of them a
japanesse to which a little bit of a
fall here I would be surprised if he's
available at 12 when the actual draft
gets here they need another pass rusher
whoever's the head coach there you can
use someone like epinasty he has power
uses his linked well but he also has
speed we've seen that over the second
half of the season in the cotton ball
season he absolutely dominated playing
right defensive end for Iowa so whether
it's a 4-3-3 for epinet is the type of
pass rusher you can build your D line
around yeah I'm with you there and it's
kind of funny maybe Vic Beasley has been
listening to the stick to football mock
drafts because he hears us take a pass
rusher for them every single Monday he
has three sacks in his last two games
Atlanta don't fall for that again you
need somebody up front let's be real
here
alright 13 the now Vegas Raiders I think
we can oh yeah official at this point
let's get this thing with a little flash
to kick ourselves off here in Vegas
Raiders Isiah Simmons we've used this
pick a couple times he is a piece on
defense that can do it all he could stop
the outside run he could play middle
linebacker outside linebacker slot
corner I'm a believer that you could
probably put the guy at strong safety
and he'd be fine high effort player an
elite top-tier athlete he really really
is but you see it on the field and if
you're a Raiders fan that hasn't gotten
to see him play this year because
Clemson plays in the ACC a lot of the
games aren't always worth watching watch
him in the college football playoff this
year and you'll be banging the table for
this guy he'll go back a lot to play
Alabama last year and yeah yeah be
jumping up on the table for sure number
14 the Cleveland Browns I'm gonna give
them another left tackles we have
three left tackles going in the top 15
here Tristan works from Iowa plays right
tackle for the hawk guys he can switch
over play on the left side no worries
there I think he only plays the right
side because their actual left tackle
aller Jackson is just not comfortable on
the right side so wharfs has power gonna
help in the run game Nick Chubb will be
very happy to see this guy Sewell Baker
Mayfield because the Browns have talent
this team it's actually hard to find a
hole where there's not a young player or
not a player we liked in the draft or
free agency they have to get better on
the offensive line there Tristan works
will answer the biggest question on this
entire roster in my opinion yeah they're
just woefully unprepared week after week
but they draft the coach as much as I
would like to and I know it got around a
lot this weekend I've been talking to a
lot of people the last week Matt there
it's hard to find somebody that thinks
Freddie's getting fired it's hard
now when you embarrass yourself week
after week maybe they're gonna build the
case here but I'm not sold that the
Browns will be looking for a new head
coach just yet there's a lot of time but
that would be a mistake in my opinion
they got to get this thing right while
this roster is that good 15 the
Indianapolis Colts I'm going past rusher
here Yeats or grouse Tomatoes I know
they've taken a decent amount of edge
guys they signed Justin Houston I still
think the long-term future of the
position has some question marks I also
think this is something me and Matt
talked about before we started the show
today there's a drop-off in talent in
the second half of this round that is
significantly higher than usual
where if you're sitting in the top 16
picks and you're not looking at one of
the deep positions like running back or
wide receiver it's hard to find really
top-tier see you know high-impact round
1 talent and that's why if I'm the Colts
I'm not gonna pass on grouse made us in
this spot he's been very good against
the run he's just loaded up with traits
to rush the passer
he's got good length I love with this
guy's game I think he needs to be a
little more consistent but he's a young
player that'll get there yeah if you'd
like to Brian burns last year then
you're gonna made us yeah I mean it's
same type of dude maybe not as
consistent but same type of dude number
16 at Philadelphia
I mean they have to get speed on offense
that wide receiver
Henry rugs comes in that is his game to
a tee
carson wentz i know it has had a lot of
critics this year carson is doing
everything he can he just doesn't have
any help a wide receiver hey Gregg
Ward's out there trying to save the
season they need to give him help Henry
rugs K top off the defense he can help
Bunny AK plays I think that he's gonna
get typecast by some people as just a
deep threat I see him as so much more
than that
rugs can answer a lot of the Eagles
problems here Connor in the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers or on the clock buddy a
little fun fact here Matt Jameis Winston
can break the single season passing
yards record how wild is that I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure he's in the
conversation for it I am so this wasn't
planned to talk about but Jamie's
through a pic on the opening drive
yesterday which happens a lot and I
tweeted like oh like jamester a pic
bucks fans got so mad at me because he
had a good game after that and they were
like oh why are you tweeting about it
now that's like guys you missed the joke
he leads the NFL in interceptions yeah
it's funny dude I'm telling you I need
to fact-check that but it is wild
he has 4,500 yards right now yeah which
is like over t is 200 and something more
than dak who's in second he's also 724
interceptions which lead oh he's just
he's just record recklessly throwing the
ball around it's been it's honestly fun
at this point 30 touchdowns 24 picks I
mean it's it's wild to me man but we do
got to make a pick for the Bucs here and
that guy will be granted to help it I
know you said this in the past Matt
getting Todd Bowles chess piece safety
would be really exciting to watch dump
it has had an up and down year I still
know he could play at a very very high
level especially closer to the line of
scrimmage which you know Jacob pastor
was telling us when we were down in
Alabama he said listen he's had to do a
lot of different things this year but if
you put him closer to the line of
scrimmage all he does is make plays and
I think Bowles is a guy that would
really know how to maximize his talent
yeah we saw that against Georgia let him
play near the line of scrimmage let him
bleed
let him make make plays in the box
number 18 the Las Vegas Raiders that
does sound weird this one from the
Chicago Bears I'm gonna be a little
crazy here I like Derek Carr and I think
with the right pieces around him we
could see him be pretty good quarterback
but I don't know that Jon Gruden seemed
a patient enough for that and I think
anyone who knows anything about Gruden
will point to the fact that he likes to
mix it up the quarterback position the
grass is always greener for him so I'm
going to give them Jordan luff a player
who I believe was gonna be a first-round
pick when it's all said and done his
traits are phenomenal and someone's
gonna talk themselves into being able to
get 2018 type of season out of him we're
Matt wells was the coach and he was
fantastic but this year he struggled he
had bad town around him no offensive
line and he did make some bad decisions
but I think Jon Gruden is gonna look at
that arm and that athleticism and say I
can I can help him be a better decision
maker I can give him you know guys
around him to make players like Josh
Jacobs and Daryl Waller baby moro Foster
Murrow excuse me
Jordan Love is gonna get the first round
I think the Raiders are a sneaky team as
of now to consider for a quarterback
yeah I think they are too I don't know
if Jordan love is the answer but I do
know that Derek Hart in my opinion is
not and I think there's some Raider fans
that feel it's not his fault
all his fault and I understand that I
just don't look at their car and go yes
that is the guy in the Gruden era that's
gonna get the Raiders not back to the
playoffs I'm talking a winning football
team a 10 11 12 13 winning football team
that should be the expectations for RIT
the Raiders with Gruden and it's gonna
be very interesting to see how they play
this out if they give Carr another
chance it's gonna be very very
interesting situation to watch 19 the
Tennessee Titans I went corner here Paul
Sinha Deebo I think a Deebo he's
obviously you know had some injuries
this year this is a very good corner
class he's kind of been a forgotten man
in this corner class I think the Titans
have had such a good find in Ryan
Tannehill ER right now where that
pressing need at quarterback has has
really lightened it's not where they
have to sit here and they have to reach
for some developmental guy anymore they
don't need to do
that they can continue loading the deck
on defense which you know Mike Vrabel
loves to do and once again I think this
is a hard part of the draft where you're
looking at the best available players
this is a team that I I'm not drafting a
wide receiver although the value would
be better here AJ Brown has been
phenomenal for them incredible that he
fell all the way to 51 so I'll go corner
here and capitalize on grabbing the d bo
yeah I'm in a corner as well 22
Jacksonville Jaguars is the pick they
got for one of the picks they got for
junior and Ramsey I'm gonna see Jay
Henderson here
I like Krista Fulton I like Paul Sena
debo I think Henderson slots in right
there with those guys there's a lot has
been made about easy physical enough
does he tackle I mean I think he's good
enough and I think what he does in
coverage is potentially special in a way
kind of like today be us why twas for me
coming out and say he's his technique is
good he's spicy and if he gets in the
right scheme where there's a good pass
rush he is going to be opportunistic
enough to flip the field and make plays
I think Henderson can be a number one
corner in Jacksonville with the type of
defense they wanna play now we're
probably gonna see a pretty big shift
there in terms of front office and
coaching but what they have in place
right now I think CJ Henderson is a
really good fit for that d 21 the Dallas
Cowboys this might be one of my favorite
pics in this mock draft Javon Kinlaw
Javon Kinlaw probably has no business
falling all the way to 21 but we see
this happen with interior defensive
linemen a lot and I think if you're
Dallas this is an area where you should
try to capitalize load up build the
front of that defense this is a Dallas
team that looked great this weekend this
was some of their best football
all-around it really really was but we
know how important drafting is going to
be for them as they've invested a lot of
money already in long term guys long
term free agents where they're gonna
have to hit on these top picks to get
some you know some cheaper impact kind
of players but I love this Dallas roster
and I think Kinlaw would be a really
really great addition for them if you
watch Sunday night Sunday afternoon
football when they're d-line is pushing
my gut they have just speed everywhere
and it makes them job real all over
it'll all be great number 22 the Miami
Dolphins actually have 22 and 23 here at
22 Connor I'm gonna give them thrill
Lewis and Ezra from Alabama a player I
hope we see the Senior Bowl who is a
graduate Junior is eligible to play
there
Louis 65 to 60 put his hand down he can
stand up he do a little bit of
everything number 22 on that Bama
defense a little bit slow early in the
air coming back from injury last year
but turned it on throughout the season
and when you talk about pass rusher
traits he has special special tools yeah
he does and I think for the Dolphins a
nice little mix of everything here you
get to it at three Louis at 22 and now
at 23 Trey Adams because you're gonna
need to add to that offensive line
they've had a rough go of it they've had
a lot of names in there that probably
didn't expect to even star in the NFL
this season that's what happens when
you're you know a team like the Dolphins
you moved Laremy Tunsil
you've probably had you know some
injuries and let's be real you're
rebuilding roster Troy Adams is a guy
that can come in he'll start from day
one he's you know super high floor
player to me the medical is the biggest
question of course long term but on the
field talent high floor to me he's clean
and pass protection he's a very good run
blocker he's tough and nasty
he's got great size and I think it's an
area that the Dolphins maybe some of the
favorite players you know like worse
Thomas wills they might already be gone
but you can still get a day one starter
in this spot Adams is gonna be at the
Senior Bowl and I think that's going to
be a huge diversity for him because my
biggest question about him from tape is
how well does he move in space because
and not just because the back injury
history but just how fluid is he and I
think we'll get to see that in Mobile
and then one month later we'll have the
combine so we'll get the medicals there
that month that's stretch there I think
it's the difference between him being a
late round pick and an early pick
because it's just medicals and movement
are gonna be huge for trae Adams number
20 for the Minnesota Vikings they need
help a corner I mean Xavier Rhodes is
falling off a cliff I like some of the
young guys there Mike Hughes is gonna be
a good player but they need more help if
Sean Wade comes out as a redshirt
sophomore I think he gets into the late
first round because there are teams here
the Vikings the Chiefs the
Niners there's just a need at corner
late in the draft with four already
having been drafted where a guy like
Shawn Wade it's a little bit all
potential because teams are really
afraid of that Ohio State secondary but
Shawn Wade has traits yeah sighs I think
there are times when teams do attack and
go to his side he's showing he has
really good ball skills and instincts so
I think next year he would be the top
corner in the draft this year I still
think he's a first rounder all right 25
the Buffalo Bills officially headed to
the postseason listen they need a big
wide receiver for Josh Allen I mean they
really really do you even saw it
that's Rohtak old Beasley it was a
little high
but you just see the lack of catch
radius on these guys that leads to
either drops interceptions you don't
have to worry about that when you have T
Higgins on the field for Buffalo here
this is a good spot for them because
they're gonna be picking late because
they're already in the playoffs and they
need to get a wide receiver they can
capitalize off of how deep this class is
so for the bills getting T Higgins who
has a million touchdowns in his last
couple games he's somebody that would
come in start from day one bring an
element to their offense that they
simply don't have which is sighs for the
red zone
sighs for the middle of the field and he
could do a little bit after the catch as
well
number 26 the Kansas City Chiefs I mean
Oh Kenneth Murray here a middle
linebacker from Oklahoma thought about
corner but they're all gone
interior offensive line feels like
that's an area they can address a little
bit later in the draft Murray
it gives them really a nickel linebacker
someone who can stay on the field all
three downs has great range sideline to
sideline and has been incredibly
productive for that Oklahoma defense
yeah Murray's all over the place and
that's a great fit right there for the
Chiefs 27 the New Orleans Saints
let's get that number to wide receiver
ylvis' kishan all we've seen how
creative Sean Payton is I mean when you
look at how he uses guys in this offense
if you get Chennault there with the Jets
it's not fair if the jet sweeps the
direct snaps the screens getting
downfield vertically and winning at the
catch point Chennault can do it all I
think he is him and CD lamb are the most
dangerous wide receivers in this class
the ball in their hands in space they
really really are I would love to see
Chanel in New Orleans yeah I would too
um sometimes you see these matchups do
you like God that just makes sense and I
like TRACON Smith I think he'll be a
decent receiver but God they need a
playmaker and tional is absolutely that
and like him and just Sean Payton like
the match up there is gonna be so much
fun trying to figure out where
everybody's lined up in that offense to
be amazing 28 the San Francisco 49ers
they need help in the secondary we saw a
last-second loss to the Falcons largely
in part because Richard Sherman was hurt
but I think they need playmakers in the
secondary Xavier McKinney from Alabama
he has the best range of any safety in
this class he's a true free safety he'll
play center field over the top whether
you're in cover one two three four
whatever it is
McKinney can play a true high safety and
take that top umbrella of the defense to
be that player over over it so with what
the Niners have you know with
Witherspoon Wilshire them in a corner
they're pretty good shape McKinney can
be a guy that really ties it all
together a free safety 29 the New
England Patriots here listen this is a
team that needs a tight end I've drafted
hunter Bryant to them over and over
again but let's do something a little
different this week we'll go with Trey
Smith and I say this in every mock draft
much like Troy Adams medicals are
everything we've seen the Patriots take
some medical risk in the past they're
actually one of the teams that seem you
know less afraid to do that whether it
was Dominique Easley a long time ago
Malcolm Mitchell was another one and
then Sony Michelle actually had some
pretty tough medicals as well Trey Smith
is someone where he fits what they love
and their offensive linemen nasty tough
versatile kind of guy that they can run
the rock behind he could play tackle he
can play guard and I think for the
Patriots we've seen a lot of holes on
this offensive line this year due to
injuries I don't know if Tom's gonna be
there next year but it doesn't matter
who's playing quarterback they really
really need to keep adding pieces up
front that includes tight end and
offensive line yeah we talked about it
before the show I don't know if they're
plugging holes or building for the
future and this offseason will tell us a
lot about that number 30 the Green Bay
Packers
Dylan Moses has no business
around here but because he got hurt
early this year we don't really know
where he's at in terms of his rehab back
from the ACL injury if healthy I think
till Moses would have been a top-10
player in this class he is special
the Packers need a middle linebacker
they can afford to if most isn't gonna
be ready week one they can afford to
take a flier on this guy late round one
because the value is exceptional but he
is exactly what their defense needs with
what they have now in the pass rush was
rashon Gary coming up on the D line you
got a good corner child Alexander Dillon
Moses could really tie that defense
together it's just all a matter of is he
healthy yeah I think that's gonna be the
big question for him and I think if he
checks out medically Matt will get away
from the days of having Dylan Moses in
the bottom four picks of this draft
it'll be more closer to the top 20 top
15 kind of spots 31 the Seattle Seahawks
I'm going with Tyler B Aatish here the
center from Wisconsin I think when you
look at Seattle they're a team that
could prop their offensive line it's not
great it's also not horrible I think
they could use some pieces on the
interior here and I think they're a team
with Russell Wilson where you know it'd
be great to get this run game going
full-throttle it would be great to keep
him clean and pass protection as he
doesn't he doesn't age at all Russell
Wilson but like every other quarterback
you would love to have a really good
offensive line for him as he gets into
his mid-30s so I think I look at B
Aatish here he's somebody that can
finish easily as a top 25 top 20 player
on any big board it just as a positional
value thing where he'll probably fall
closer to back end around 1 or top 40
yeah I think with him it's a lot like
you know guys like Frank rag know in
previous years or Billy Price where
there's many teams that love them and
you know like it's just a really solid
player it's just a matter where they
fall but he would be a really good fit
there number 32 the Baltimore Ravens I
don't know what this team needs because
they look unbeatable right now and
they're young at the right positions I
really thought losing CJ Mosely
would have a huge impact on this defense
it is not they're still fine
I really thought losing trails Suggs
huge impact nope maybe Matt Jude on
being a free agent will point us in the
direction where they're gonna go and
free agency but excuse me in the draft
I like Giuliano
or even if Jude on its back I would like
to see them add younger pass rushers
just build up what they have there you
know guys like Tim Williams never hit
highest Bowser hasn't really hit get
younger at the pass rush position keep
throwing picks at it but again I don't I
don't know that this team needs anything
because they've taken down everyone in
the NFL and no one can seem to figure
out how to stop lamar jackson or how to
slow down that defense so the ravens
congratulations you look like you're
probably gonna be seeing us in miami in
a couple months draft on draft time here
we go first question up from dam supa
the Bucs are going to be too good to get
a quarterback barring a trade do they
roll with the highs and lows of Jameis
or just hit the refresh button man I
feel like they're gonna roll with Jameis
for one more year it's not what I was
used to but it feels that way it feels
like Bruce Arians he's gonna look at the
fact that like you said Connor he's
leading the NFL in yards yes he's also
leading in interceptions but they're
probably gonna say okay well now he
knows the offense he'll cut down on the
mistakes next year I think it's fool's
gold but it feels like that's what
they're gonna do yeah I think so too
because you know they've won a decent
amount of games where they've gotten
themselves out of the territory of
getting one of these quarterbacks now I
can see a world where maybe Jacob Eason
declares and Bruce doesn't really care
what the opinions are of him and he says
listen that's my kind of quarterback
we'll take them the problem is it also
depends what kind of contract you have
Jameis on I mean if you have Jameis
getting guaranteed money into you know
at least three years then you're not
going to take a Jacob Eason or any round
one quarterback because it would be a
complete waste so it's interesting for
the Bucs but it's it's come back to
where I'm starting to lean the other way
again where Jameis might be in a bizarro
way the best option short term I just
wouldn't feel good about giving him any
kind of big contract next up Myles
Jameson is an athletic Jared Goff a good
cop for Joe borough if not what is a
good comp I kind of see that I think in
body type especially you kind of see
that because they're both kind of skinny
kids Boro has put on a little bit of
weight I just feel like Joe is so good
in the pocket and I don't think Golf is
a little aloof at times in the pocket I
don't know what the Kampf is for burrow
because he's his size you don't look at
like I think he moves around the pocket
too well for a guy his size so it's it's
tough I don't I sometimes I think it's
drew brees sometimes I said Jimmy
Garoppolo was the one I gave him early
in the year I know Melo has said in the
pocket he's like Tom Brady with his
pocket poised I don't I don't have a
copy it's completely blank next to his
name in my scouting database because
there's just there's not anyone that I
get a great feel it's like oh that's
that Subaru is I mean I Tony Romo maybe
but is a hot one right now and I don't
like it I don't either
but I hear it a lot so I don't know I'll
let you guys know and Arnold's were very
similar and I don't see darn 'old and
burrow being simple I agree with that a
lot so that's my problem with reused
cops yeah I don't I don't think they're
he's just so smooth and I don't know
that there is anyone in the NFL where
you're like watching him move through
the pocket and eyes are always downfield
and he can make athletic throws it's
just not really anyone that fits that
mold in my opinion yeah it'll be tough
he he'll probably be a throwback cop
somewhere
yeah player of the last 15 years rather
than the last three or three to five
which you know throws people off a
little bit but those cops take longer to
come up with and I think I enjoy them
more because it's it's more of a
research project than rather just us
having nine levian bells every single
right we're 12 Aaron Rodgers like that's
yeah so it's a great question though and
I'm looking forward to seeing you know
what he ultimately ends up being written
as Andrew Magnussen does a player's
decision to skip a bowl game or it's a
climb to go to the Senior Bowl effect
how a player is viewed / evaluated not
for us but I would waste one of preface
these because every evaluator is human
right and so there could be a GM who
pisses them off that a guy doesn't go to
the Senior Bowl I've heard stories of
this happening I've heard stories of
teams being really mad at Josh Allen
from Kentucky didn't go last year and
then it maybe pushed him down in the
draft some
so I think it can but it doesn't for me
if the guy skips a ballgame that's their
decision doesn't really bother me one
way or the other I think it's just part
of the job the guy decides not to go to
the Senior Bowl we can have an opinion
on if that was a good decision or not
but ultimately I don't know that it's
gonna hurt a player stock for me so much
I think the Senior Bowl is more just a
missed opportunity so it's not gonna
move you down if you skip but you missed
an opportunity to move up more more I
guess the better way to put it Matt this
is the rare week where I actually have a
draft on girafft question here we go and
it's kind of useless now because the
Giants a lot of teams won yesterday but
the Giants won yesterday but when the
Bengals were giving the Patriots a game
and the Giants were potentially gonna
lose I wondered if the Giants somehow
ended up picking number one would you
draft Joe burrow and trade Daniel Jones
oh man it's not gonna happen not no you
take chase young yeah I would and and I
say that I don't know like Daniel Jones
I don't think he's that good but I just
feel like your return on investment at
that point is is really really bad I
thought it was interesting it's I don't
know what I would do and I think people
will like label me as a daniel Jones
hater and that's not the case I don't
even know what I would do but it was
interesting because I heard back from a
lot of Giants fans and it was the
responses were split the vote was the
draft chase young yeah that one at 54%
but there was people that were like man
it would be very hard for me to pass on
taking jobber oh he's good I mean he's
really watching him in person again that
was mind blowing yeah like it's a
reminder of how good he and you know
we've seen him play four times in the
last two years on tailgate tour and he's
never lost the game that we've been at
know it is crazy when you think about
that if there's anybody we've seen more
of it's Joe burrow right so all right
last one of the day Jeremy Thompson
can you guys start floating car to the
Bears so the Raiders can get their
second rounder back Thanks do you guys
really want him though that's I put this
in here because they
I don't know that the Bears will do you
one that's a bad fit over mitts true
Biscay I I mean I get everybody you know
hates on Mitch but and I get the the
question was kind of like you know in a
in a sarcastic funny way
what is car worth is the question I
don't know anymore
oh man it really is well I have to look
at the guarantees no they dry up they
dry up really quick so next year he only
has five million in dead money if he's
cut this was the big year this was the
twenty seven over 27 and dead money of
cuts so this was really the last full
year of money and then it just it really
goes down to five million then 2.5
million than zero so I might give up a
third for him I would - I would - I
think yeah I would - it's interesting
I'll say I'll say this though Matt I saw
a weird stat he's like horrific in games
below 50 degrees yeah they came to
Kansas City a couple weeks ago that was
ever that's all anyone talked about like
he has to be in warm weather or you know
send him to New Orleans let him take
over for Drew Brees he could play in a
dome Oh keep teddy
that's what they should do yeah but
you're the Bears you don't want him why
I mean it's always cold there no I don't
that's why I just don't think and I know
the weather thing people it gets
overblown but it's a real thing with him
the reason I saw that was because it was
the graphic before he played the Jets at
New York and I think it was like 43
degrees that day and he was 15 at 27 for
127 yards no touchdowns in a pic I will
never forget the first the nuts first
game I think was his first NFL game I
saw so Thursday night er in Kansas City
if the other Raiders were really good he
was eight degrees out he broke his hand
Raiders lost and it was just I mean he
does not want to be outside in the cold
which I don't really either but I'm not
an NFL quarterback yeah alright that is
our show buddy Wednesday
give me a fun one we
Christmas presents Santa Claus time yeah
Santa time I had a curfew in Santa suits
I'm Michelle ooh I might get a hat at
least I could I could dig mine up yeah I
didn't I didn't shave while I was sick
and so I did this morning I I had a lot
of white in the beard I'm not gonna lie
a couple years kept it too early yeah I
really should have kept it but we will
be handing out presents Connors got the
AFC I have the NFC we'll be back
Wednesday morning handing those out for
you guys so thank you for hanging out
with us we'll talk to you real soon